tonight a pretty big party right yeah I
know it's very very hectic and awesome I
know that's so many people coming
through right now are you looking
forward to them we're wanting to know
are you looking forward to smashing a
guitar tonight I'm literally so excited
to smash next are the fact that I get to
stand next to Morgan Freeman and smashed
a guitar is literally it's I mean thank
you hard rock dreams come true how's
life going for you right now
good busy tired
what everybody's just doing a quick
little job walk it in thank you for
taking time to stop and chat with it we
you know you're very vocal is on what
you're going through in your life right
now we're at seven points in your life
so that was maybe the romance department
everything's going in great and yeah
yeah things are great me and Ben are
really happy and he comes to LA the
first week in November to be fun so yes
you know he's on tour doing his his
album release right now so it's just a
lot of work for him and a lot of work
for me in separate places
[Music]